-From Studio 60
in Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's a special
five-minute edition
of "The Tonight Show"
starring Jimmy Fallon.
It's the "Fallon Five."
And now, here's your host,
Jimmy Fallon!
-♪ Hey, hey hey, hey ♪
-Thank you very much!
Please, welcome, welcome!
Thank you.
Please stop clapping.
We only have five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
We're already --
The show's already over.
Uh, Paul Rudd will be out here
in a little bit
but first, here's
what people are talking about.
You guys, today is day 11
of the 2018 Winter Olympics!
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...while it is day 12
of Fergie's National Anthem
at the NBA All-Star game.
-Hey-oh!
-It's still going on.
It's still going on now.
Yeah.
Did you see this?
Everybody is talking about this.
At the NBA All-Star game
last night, Fergie performed a
pretty interesting rendition
of the National Anthem.
It was a pretty
creative take on the song.
[ Laughter ]
Just watch the players'
reactions -- This is real.
-♪ Gave proof ♪
♪ Through the night ♪
♪ That our flag
was still there ♪
♪ Oh, oh, say ♪
♪ Does that star-spangled
banner-er ye-yet wave ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I don't wanna say it was rough,
but even Trump took a knee.
I mean, that's when you're like,
you know, she's that bad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ As Trump ] Wall.
I saw that German figure skater
Paul Fentz went viral
when he did his free skate to
music from "Game of Thrones."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
Yeah, pretty cool.
[ Laughter ]
It worked even better when
he tried using another
TV show theme song.
Watch this.
-Next up, representing Germany,
Paul Fentz.
-♪ Who lives in a pineapple
under the sea ♪
-♪ Spongebob Squarepants ♪
-♪ Absorbent and yellow
and porous is he ♪
-♪ Spongebob Squarepants ♪
[ Applause ]
-Spongebob!
Ooh, a bit of a scandal.
A bit of a scandal here.
A member of the Russian curling
team failed a drug test
and is being accused
of cheating.
[ Light laughter ]
Now, I don't really know
if doping would really affect
the outcome of a sport
like curling, but --
[ Laughter ]
Take a look at this guy.
Watch this.
[ Audience applauding ]
[ Explosion ]
Just a little bit.
You know, it's unfair.
It's unfair.
[ Laughter ]
Another big story right now
is U.S. Hockey.
The women are going
for the gold,
while the men are close
to being eliminated.
Which also kind of sums up
the year 2018.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!
[ Playing Queen's
"Under Pressure" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, our show tonight is
only five minutes long,
which means we don't have enough
time for a normal interview.
But that won't stop me, no.
I still want to make sure that
we give you guys everything
that you'd normally get
so with that in mind,
it is time for the
first-ever "Tonight Show"
one-minute interview.
Here we go.
-♪ One-minute interview ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm going to do an entire
interview
with tonight's guest
in just one minute,
so let's put 60 seconds
on the clock.
Ready?
Here we go.
Our guest tonight is a very
funny, very talented actor.
His new movie "Mute" comes out
on Netflix this Friday.
Everyone, please welcome back
a friend of the show, Paul Rudd!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Paul, great to see you.
How is it going?
-Really good.
-The Winter Olympics are
happening right now.
Have you been watching those?
-I have been -- it's great.
-What is your favorite Olympic
sport?
-Well, I love skiing, but --
-Do you consider yourself...
[ Laughter ]
...athletic, an athletic person?
I like sports a lot.
I played soccer when I was --
-Let's talk about your new
movie, "Mute."
Can you tell us a little bit
about it?
-It's kind of a sci-fi --
-That's more than enough.
[ Laughter ]
Do you wear a mustache in the
film?
-I do.
-What was that like?
-Crazy.
-Let's take a look at a clip
from "Mute."
-Don't do that again.
-That looks great.
Hey, do you want to sing?
-Yes.
-Oh, perfect.
Let's sing a song right now.
-♪ You know you make me want
to shout ♪
♪ Kick my heels up and shout,
throw my hands up and shout ♪
♪ Throw my head back and shout ♪
♪ A little bit lower now, shout,
a little bit lower now, shout ♪
♪ A little bit louder now
a little bit louder now ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Bell dings ]
Thank you very much, Paul Rudd!
Catch "Mute" on Netflix
this Friday.
Thank you for watching.
Have a great night.
Hope to see you tomorrow.
Bye-bye, everybody!
[ The Roots continue
playing "Shout" ]